ام
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله قال المتحدث باسم
القوات المسلحه المصريه العقيد احمد عليه
في مقابله مع صحيفه نيوز المصري المستقله
ان من حق الفريق اول عبد الفتاح السيسي
الترشح لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه اذا
تقاعد من منصبه واذا كانت هذه رغبه الشعب
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين ما
دلاله الحديث عن حق الفريق السياسي في
ترشح انتخابات رئاسيه في هذا التوقيت
وما هي التاثيرات التي قد يثيرها ترشح
السيسي لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
في موقعها على شبكه الانترنت نشرت صحيفه
الديلي نيوز المصري المستقله توضيحا
لتصريحات ادلى بها المتحدث باسم القوات
المسلحه العقيد احمد علي بشان حق وزير
الدفاع الفريق اول عبد الفتاح السيسي في
الترشح لانتخابات الرئاسه المصريه
وقالت الصحيفه ان دافعها لنشر التوضيح هو
سيد الاستفسارات التي انهالت عليها تستوضح
عن الخبر
واضافت انها انطلقت في سؤالها لاحمد علي
المتحدث باسم القوات المسلحه المصريه
انطلقت من من تنامي الشعبيه السياسي في
الشارع المصري وليس مطلقا من علمها باي
دور سياسي يخطط له الرجل للعبه في المرحله
المقبله
عسكري محترف لديه استعداد ل احتراف
السياسه فهل سيفعل وجد الرئيس المصري
المعزول في الفريق الشاب المتدين صاحب
الادوار القياديه في المخابرات الحربيه ما
يؤهله لتولي وزاره الدفاع وقياده الجيش
حينها خرج موقع حزب الحريه والعداله ليصف
الفريق بوزير دفاع بنكهه الثوره كانت تلك
ربما رغبه من الرئيس مرسي في تكريس خضوع
الجيش لاول رئيس مصري مدني منتخب في
انتخابات حره لكن الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
السيسي ما لبث ان تحرك بعد عام ل عزل
الرئيس مرسي على وقع تظاهرات شعبيه حاشده
طالبت برحيله
ومنذ الثلاثين من يونيو واسم السياسي على
كل لسان لا بل ان شعبيته اخذت تصاعد في
الشارع المصري حسب بعض المصادر يقول
منتقدو والمتوج سون من عوده المؤسسه
العسكريه الى الحياه السياسيه انه حاكم
مصر الفعلي صحيح ان السياسي سلم السلطه
لحكومه مدنيه مؤقته لكنه يشغل فيها منصب
وزير الدفاع كما انه النائب الاول لرئيس
الوزراء والقائد العام للقوات المسلحه
لم يشكل مجلسا عسكريا على طريقه المشير
الطنطاوي لكنه كما قال التحليلات اثر
صناعه القاده بدلا من تولي القياده فهل
سياسي حق طموح سياسي اكبر الم ياتي حكام
مصر على مدى الستين عاما الماضيه من مؤسسه
الجيش والجيش نفسه اذار البلاد كما نذكر
طوال الاشهر السته عشر المضطربه التي
اعقبت الثوره على نظام مبارك منذ ذاك
يفترض ان الثوره اعاده الجنود الى ثكناتهم
انا قسمت من لم يحلم المجتمع تشوف ما في
اي حد
نحنا نشوف بلدنا بلدنا مصر
لكن اشكاليه الجيش والسياسه لا تنتهي
بعبارات طمانه ومع ذلك يؤكد المتحدث
العسكري المصري ان الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
السيسي لا يطمح في اي مناصب سياسيه لانه
الان جندي في القوات المسلحه
لكن ما يمنع الجنديه او الاصح القائد
العام للقوات المسلحه من خوض الانتخابات
الرئاسيه اذا خلع زيه العسكري
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيوفنا في
الاستوديو محمد الجوادي المؤرخ والباحث
السياسي ومن القاهره اللواء طلعت مسلم
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
على انه سينضم الينا ايضا القاهره عبد
الحميد عمران الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
مرحبا بضيوفنا الكرام اه استاذ محمد
الجوادي من خلال معرفتك بالتاريخ ال ال
المصري المعاصر ودور المؤسسه العسكريه في
الحكم
كيف تلقيت انت اه هذا الخبر احتمال ان
يترشح السيسي للرئاسه
وعلى لسان المتحدث باسم المؤسسه العسكريه
هو يعني تصريح كشف عن اشياء كنا نعرفها
لكننا لم يكن يجرؤ على التحدث فيها
احتراما لخصوصيه القوات المسلحه من ناحيه
واحتراما الخصوصيات سوف ثوره 25 يناير من
ناحيه اخرى
وحتى لا ندخل بانفسنا الى مناطق الاسلاك
الشائكه من ناحيه ثالثه لكننا جميعا في
الحياه السياسيه المصريه سمعنا عن حوار
متكرر دار بين الفريق السيسي من ناحيه
وبين قيادات سياسيه مختلفه في اكثر لن
اتحدث عن الحوارات عن دخوله السياسه اه لن
اتحدث عن حوارات في غرف الجانبيه او في
الغرف المغلقه وانما ساتحدث عن حوارات
علنيه دارت امام الجماهير كلها وزعت في
القنوات التلفزيونيه
منها على سبيل المثال الحوار الذي دار فيه
قاعده دكتور عندما قال الفريق السيسي اذا
اردتم ان تغير بالرئيس وزاراتهم ان تغير
الحاكم فعليكم ب صناديق الانتخاب
الانتخاب معناها
انه يؤيد الكلام الذي كان يقوله الدكتور
موسى بعدها اذار الحوار حول
انه
الشعب ممثلا في هؤلاء يريدون قياده حازمه
حاسمه لانهم تعودوا على الحجم العزم وان
مثلا
معها الا الحازم الحادث المقصود الحاكم
العسكري الفرعون لكن التعبير الجميل هو
الحازمه والتعبير المهني الحكم العسكري
والتعبير التاريخي هو عبد الناصر يعني
هناك اربعه
تعبيرات اربع
موضوعيه اذا اردت ان تسميه في الشخص تسميه
عبد الناصر قال الفريق شفيق انه البلد
حلها من يوم عبد الناصر ما ت يعني واحد
يمسك جامد اذا اردت ان استخدم كلمه واحده
لهذا لان في عليك بكلمه فرعون اذا اردت
كلمه بلديه مبطنه فهي الحاكم الحادث اذا
على هذا ان هذا الحديث لم يكن
على
يعني هكذا وانما دعني اكمل الحديث لانه
الوقت
فريق سياسي انه القوات المسلحه جربت حظها
مع الشعب في السنتين الاخيرتين وقد تم
تقولون يسقط يسقط حكم العسكر وكيف ندخل
الانتخابات وان تمكن من هنا جاء التعديل
الدستوري الذي لم يتم حتى الان لكن
المحكمه الدستوريه بعثت به الى مجلس
الشورى في سته وعشرين خمسه الفائت وهو انه
حق العسكريين في ممارسه حقوقهم السياسيه
حقوقهم السياسيه تشمل الترشيح والانتخابات
الامر كان المدبر له من قبل الحقيقه هذا
وانتهى الموضوع من يريد ان يقرا فليقرا
ومن يريد ان يتعامل عن قراءه جاء من هذه
المحكمه الدستوريه قرارات المحكمه نشر في
الجريده الرسميه يعني هذا ليس ليس شفويا
ولا لكنه ينشط الجريده الرسميه
في سته وعشرين ماي
انه حقهم في ممارسه حكومه السياسيه التي
هي يعني
لانه ليس له ان لانه
لسراح للشورى وشو راح تتعدل في الانتخابات
عملهم تعديلات القصه المشهوره بتاع
يعني
كان الخوف الذي جعلنا نتحدث في الامر
وقلنا ماذا لو انه قائد القوات المسلحه
ترشح وترشح ايضا قائد القوات البحريه او
ترشحه ايضا قائد الجيش التالي او ترشح
قائد الفريق
اصبح عندك اكثر من مرشح عسكريه لانك لا
تستطيع ان تقول
اسمع اسمع اللواء طلعت مسلم الخبير
العسكري الاستراتيجيه استاذنا
اه مرحبا باللواء وسلم في خضم حاله
استقطاب الحاده هذه التي يشهدها الشارع
المصري الان ما معنى الحديث عن احتمال
ترشح الفريق اول عبد الفتاح السيسي
للرئاسه
يعني اولا انا اعتقد انه الحديث لم ياتي
بمبادره من القوات المسلحه والمتحدث
باسمها
من الفريق سيتي او من غيره وانما هو جاء
من ال الجديده التي كانت تجري الحديث
وبالتالي كان هذا طبيعي الرد
لم يكن هناك في اي وقت من الاوقات ما يمنع
اه اي ضغط يترك الخدمه انه احنا بعد ان اه
يتقاعد من الخدمه وهكذا كان رد المتحدث
باسم القوات المسلحه اه على السؤال الصح
هل هذا الكلام
لواء مثلا هذا الكلام هل هو ملزم لاحمد
علي فقط يعني هذا رايي الشخصي
ام للمؤسسه العسكريه وهي لم جيدا انه يجري
حديثا صحفيا باسم القوات المسلحه وليس
بصفته الشخصيه وكان يمكن حتى لو كان وقع
خطا مثلا حتى لا يفهم كلامه لان المساله
ليست مساله هينه ان يتصل بالصحفي قبل نشره
ويطلب منه مثلا حتى هذا ال هذا ال هذه
النقطه
او تكليف كذلك يا سيدي ليس هذا ليس سؤالا
هذا ليس سؤالا القوات المسلحه والا
المتحدث باسمها لان هنا الحديث عن حق من
حق اه وزير الدفاع او غير من الضباط ان
يترشحوا للرئاسه بعد تركيا من خدمه ام لا
هذا هو السؤال في الحقيقه وان كانت تركز
على
بالنسبه لاي شخص يرد على هذا سؤال لابد من
يقول انه من حق اي ضابط في الخدمه في
القوات المسلحه
اي منظم طالما انها القانون لا لا يمنع من
ذلك وهذا ما حدث بالنسبه لل
لا بد اننا نقول انه ايضا السؤال بيعكس
الشعور ب اه
زياده شعبيه الفريق او كوزير للدفاع
باعتبار انه استجابه ل اه مطالب الشعب
وقطعا اه اه لا بد اننا انا اقول انه
شعبيته في هذه الفتره بدرجه كبيره واعلن
او الان يقول لك اه مركز في قلوب اه نسبه
عاليه
حتى والاجهزه ان استخدم كلمه الشعب حينما
سجل من استجاب في ثلاثين ا يعني اه اه
هؤلاء لم يخرجوا يطلبوا من السياسي ان
يغير بل خرجوا ليعبر عن مطالبهم وتحرك
الجيش من منطلق انه كما قال وجدان البلاد
ربما قد تنزلق نحو مصير مجهول ان يتدخل في
هذه اللحظه و يقوم بما قام به وليس من اجل
اه اه شعبيه الرجل القوي من اجل مطلب شعبي
يطالب السيسي ان يكون الرجل القيادي الان
لا المطلب الشعبي كان الحقيقه ان كان ال
اه وزير الدفاع مطالب باجراء التغيير
بالنيابه عن الشعب ونذكر ان في ذلك الوقت
هناك من اه وقع
توكيلات لوزير الدفاع في التغيير وكانت
هناك دعوات صريحه على نفع على صفحات تصاعد
بان اه بانه يقوم بالتغيير وبالرغم من هذا
فقد
امتنع وزير الدفاع عن القيام باي شيء من
هذا القبيل انه بان رغبه الشعب لم تتضح
وكان الفيصل بالنسبه ل وهو صندوق الانتخاب
وهو في نفس الوقت ما عرضه على اه الدكتور
مرسي علشان يجري استفتاء على الرئاسه وهو
ما ربطوا الدكتور اه هذا ما حدث وهذا ما
يؤكد ان الفريق السيسى هو استجاب لمطالب
الشعب وليس اكثر من يعني على كل حال نحن
نبحث في ال الجزء الثاني من من الحلقه اه
اه تاثيرات احتمال ترشح السيسي على
المشاهدين السياسي والامني ايضا في مصر
على مشاهدينا الكرام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي تسجل
اتى تصريح المتحدث باسم القوات المسلحه
مصريه عن حق ووزير الدفاع الحالي في
الترشح للرئاسه مرحبا بضيوفنا الكرام اه
دكتور محمد جواد برايك كيف سيكون لهذه ال
فرضيه فرضيه ان يترشح الفتاح السيسي
للرئاسه على المشهد من تاثير على المشهد
السياسي في مصر بشقيه سواء في المعسكر
الذي يؤيد الرئيس المعزول محمد مرسي او
الذين عارضوا تسمح لي ان اناقشها على ثلاث
فرديه
الدقيقه الاولى في الماضي يعني قبل
الثلاثين يوم كان هناك اتفاق على ذلك على
على ان يتولى الرئاسه اه
التعديل كان تمهيدا لكن كانت المساله ان
احنا
انت الرئيس انت الامير واضح من من ول اه
يعني
انصار سوريا في
التعبير المصري البسيط
الممولون الشركه القابضه للاحزاب التي
يمولها هناك سبعه احزاب تجتمع في الشركه
ال قبل الاحزاب يمولها رجل العمل
لا يعني طبعا هو
يعني انشاء الله شارون
لو عليهم شارون بدلا من مرسله قبل بدلا من
مرسي قبل
في المستوى الحاضر انه في الظروف اللي حصل
فيها الشعب الوقتي واضح جدا انه في الشارع
اقوى من
المجموعه 7 7 14 7 واحد وعشرين سبعه اقوى
بكثير من من ثلاثين سته في اعاده حسابات
زي ما انت شايف اخبار تم له للصحفي بيسال
فيها المتحدث العسكري
تجري بالونات الاختبارات الى ان تشكل هناك
الاختبار بالدبوس ستنفجر
في المستقبل دعنا نتحدث انه فرضنا وتقدم
الفريق السيسي يتقدم غيره من قاده القوات
المسلحه حتى يصبح الحكم القوات البحريه
تؤيد الفريق السياسي
سبعه وثمانين يؤيد المرشح المنافس وهكذا
يعني دخلنا في المعركه في الجيش
اذا دخلنا ل هذه المعمعه التي تذكرنا
جمهوريات الموز فاننا نتذكر نستدعي من
تاريخنا واقعتين الواقع الاحدث في الواقع
الماساويه هي موقعه عبد الحكيم عامر
الجيش المصري الذي قتل وزيره الجيش المصري
الذي اعدم وزيره
الجيش المصري الذي انقسم كيف يمكن ان تسقط
هذه الحاله الواقع الان
ذاتها لكن نشوف ان تصل الى
المثل البعيد الديني او احنا بس عشان
انه الخمسين كان وزير الدفاع المدني حطينا
ومسلمه في خمسين في وزاره الوارث من حيث
انه يكون ايضا مدنيه الملكه رخصه من
الفريق حيدر توصلنا
طيب اه يعني اه
النقاش حول مساله
اللواء طلعت مسلم الخبير العسكري
الاستراتيجي اسال يعني الكل كان يتحدث بعد
ثوره خمسه وعشرين اكبر انجاز واهم اذا
تحقق في هذه الثوره هو مدنيه الدوله هو ان
المدنيين هم الذين بات الان يكون بزمام
الامور
والحكم في البلاد الا يسلم اسلوب هذا
الامر اذا تحقق اذا ترشح السيسي للرئاسه
هذه الثوره اهم ايجاز لها وهو هذا الامر
مدنيه الدوله
اللواء طلعت مسلم
للاسف ليس اللواء طلعت مسلم واضر اللواء
ليس صوتك ان يصل اعود مره اخرى الى
الاستاذ محمد الجوادي هل هل تعتقد بان هذا
الامر قد يكون له فعلا اه تفاعل كبير في
الساحه المصريه هل سيكون له اي تاثير على
ما يجري الان في الوقت الذي يتم البحث عن
حل
في البحث عن حل لا يمكن ان يكون له تاثير
لكن في البحث عن تعقيد يكون له تاثير يعني
اذا اردت ان تحل المشكله فانك لابد ان
تجنب هذا جانبا نهائيا لك ان يكون السياسي
مثلا حكما بين السلطات مع الاحترام
والتقدير لا يكون حكما بين سلطه اذا اردت
ان تعقد المشكله للمعادله والناس في
الداخليه والناس في امن الدوله والحاجات
دي يقولون انه الانتخابات مضمونه بالطرق
التي كانت تجري قبل ذلك يجيب خمسه وتسعين
في المائه وخمسين يجيب واحد في المائه
والبرادعي واحد في المائه وعم ن عم بيجيب
واحد في المائه هو ثلاث اربعه ان كل واحد
منهم اجيب واحد من عشره في المائه
وهل سيسلم وكل هؤلاء بالامر
وسواء التيار الاخواني
تيارات اسلاميه تيارات اخرى
تصور اللي موجود انه الاخوان يمتنع فاذن
اللي انتخبهم اللى مش اخوان
فاذن انت خمسه وتسعين في المائه من يكون
ان شاء الله عشره في المائه كما بطريقه
داخليه في تكمله الاصوات اللي كانت ايام
حسني مبارك ستين سنه يعني يعني اذا
انسداد الافق امام الحل مع تشبت كل طرف قد
يقبل الطرف ان هذا الامر كحل الوسط تجنب
البلاد
وبالتالي
يعني انت قلت انت بطريقه ذكيه جدا يمكن ان
لم ترقى الى مستوى سؤال انه لو هو في الحل
يبقى لا اقول اذا عشان تحل الازمه لابد ان
سيخرج منها
يبقى اذن سيكون سيكونوا يعني حل مشكله
مشكله لكن اذا اذا دخل في المشكله المشكله
يعني الان لا تتوقف على رجل واحد في مصر
اول او المشير السيسى نائب رئيس الوزراء
ونائب رئيس الوزراء ووزير الدفاع
كانت الامور كلها معلقه بهذا الرقم لو
ادخل نفسه طرف منافس ازداد التعقيد لو خرج
من المشكله وقال ان نجلس طرفا منها وانني
ساحكم بين موسى وبين محمد الجوادي ستحل
المشكله
يعني اذا افترضنا من القوى المدنيه اتفقت
على محمل الجد واصبح بين محمد الجوائز
فاذن سيحكم تحل المشكله لكن لو دخل
السياسي واصبحت اسمح لي انضم الينا اه
الان عبد الحميد اه امران وهو محمد عمر ان
الخبير العسكري الاستراتيجي اللواء يعني
اه تحدثنا الدكتور محمد جواد عن مساله اه
للاسف ان تنضم الينا متاخره جدا ونحن ذلك
لان هناك ط سني لكن ال المساله الان مساله
اه وفاق او عدم تحقق هذا الوفاق حول هذا
الرجل كمخرج البناء كحل وسط سؤالي هو اذا
كان السياسيون بالتاكيد الحضور ان يكون
هناك عسكري مره اخرى على راس هرم الدوله
ما طبيعه رد الفعل التي قد تكون داخل
المؤسسه العسكريه نفيها في حال ترشح
السيسي
للرئاسه
اه
المبدا لا بس انه كمواطن فقط بدون الرتب
اللي على
لكن وهذا يكون لصالح الدوله اما الدوله
بيكون واحد عنده
بها الطريقه اكثر
لكن تحديدا لموقف النهار ده بعد ان قام
بالغاء الدستور
الاجراء كلها
هذا غير صحيح
هذا
بنفس الموقف مره اخرى عندما كان المشير
حسين طنطاوي
بالملابس المدنيه وعلى احد المدعين انه
الجمهوريه
تذكر ولو للحظه واحده في الترشح لرئاسه
الجمهوريه حتى كان هذا من
ان كان
ستكون قد نفسك والقوات المسلحه
المصداقيه التي تحتلها طويله السيد المشير
حربنا كيف احنا كثيرا ونقول للشعب ان
الجيش السلطه الان تقول لك ان تقول له انك
وان
السيد مشير لقد رايت على مصانع السياسيين
الذين يدعون شعوبهم ومن على تنظيم هذه
الشعوب وانا ان
تاريخ العسكري الوقت وتاريخ المشرف
قد يكون فيه من عطايا او اخطاء جمهور
ان هذا الامر ليس في مخيلتك من المحيطين
وانها كانت
ربما لم يستطيع
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كان معنا من
القاهره اشكرك واشكر ايضا ضيفنا هنا في
الاستوديو محمد الجوادي المؤرخ والباحث
السياسي كما اشكر ضيفي رافقنا وثلاث الجزء
الاول اه في الحلقه طلعت مسلم الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي وشكرا لكم مشاهدي
الكرام لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء الحريري
ام
[موسيقى]